[Music]
jessica is with us in Columbus Ohio hi
Jessica how are you I'm good how are you
Dave better than I deserve what's up
okay so I recently have discovered your
YouTube channel and I had started
listening and I've started in mind it's
baby steps and I'm on baby set number
two but I'm also married and I currently
tried to talk to him a little bit and
get him involved also and the problem
that I'm having is like we don't have a
lot of money issues like we've never
I've had you know previously like I've
had the scaring I don't know what I'm
gonna do next moment and I've kind of
brought myself out of that and and
bounced back but my husband has never
had that so how do I like get him to
understand you know why we need to do
this and you know he thinks that were
normal people and that you know we can
afford what we have and we're fine so
well you are normal but financially
normal sucks yes so I mean all the money
comes in all the money goes out you got
nothing looking good no money you know
that's normal and so how much debt do
you two have we're probably at about a
hundred thousand with everything like
the house oh how much of that sounds
ninety okay so you have $10,000 in
personal debts right home one and most
of that is like medical bills it's
nothing you don't have a car payment I
do but it's almost paid off so it's not
okay yeah do you have a student have
student loans no about 120,000 part that
makes me nervous about this um he's
buying real estate for his retirement
because he works with his dad now you
know they work together in the company
and then he has a blowin into
and company on the side and so he's
starting to accumulate more debt and
then fix them up and rent them out and
that part makes me nervous what's the
debt that we already have so I don't
know how to navigate that how old are
you - I am 28 and he is 27 is birthdays
the 19th that's how old I was when I
went bankrupt from buying real estate I
know and I've listened than that and it
scares the crap on it good
and let me tell you what scares me is it
sounds like he's doing whatever the flip
he wants to do and it's like your
language that you use about your
decision-making in your household is as
if you're two roommates and not married
yeah he does this he does this but he
does this he does this he does this
there was no we in there no there isn't
this more he basically makes the
decision you know that's what I did and
and then I drove the car off a cliff and
then we had to recover after I screwed
up
and so uh you know I'm fearful for you
I I think you guys need to work on your
relationship to where your voice starts
being heard in the relationship because
I think you are you have your the
caution in the relationship and he's the
go go in the relationship and you need
both you need a balance of caution and
go go but if it's all go go and caution
is not listened to then we go go right
off the bridge yeah is what we do know
what yeah and I'm afraid for you I
really am because I don't think this guy
you know I think there's more going on
here than just getting him home board
with Dave Ramsey I don't think that's
the issue I think the issue is is that
you guys need to sit down have a serious
discussion about hey I'm not okay with
you borrowing money to buy all these
houses okay I'm not okay with that
because you just told me that I didn't
say that you said that and you and uni
and you know he'd knock on his little
forehead with your knuckles and go hello
in there you need to hear me
I'm not okay and you don't get to just
do whatever the flip you want to do when
we're married I'm not okay because I'll
tell you this about husbands because I'm
one of them we're a little Nick and we
don't do subtlety you have to just like
say it really plain and in our face for
us to even hear you okay you can't just
like be dropping the pans in the kitchen
and he's going what's wrong Manny you
know we can't read your freaking mind
you have to say I'm not okay were you
borrowing all this freaking money and
not talking to me about it and me not
being involved in the decision I'm just
not okay with the process we're using to
make financial decisions around this
house right now I've got to be part of
the decision-making and that's not
unreasonable as a matter of fact it's
unreasonable the way it's operating
today and it's headed towards a problem
now I don't hope y'all don't have to go
through what women go through maybe he's
not as stupid as I was maybe he can hold
it all together
but this idea of I'm buying real estate
I'm buying real estate and it doesn't
matter if you borrow money because
you're buying real estate the renters
gonna pay the payment it's a bunch of
crap those renters don't always pay and
there's not always a renter and then
when they move out you have to pay to
put the stuff back in the house that was
torn up or worn out and so rental real
estate is is not a poor man's game and
right now you got no money you have no
money and you're playing in rental real
estate that's just not a good place to
be so I think you got to start with that
and then you back into okay let's go to
Financial Peace University or let's go
to something where we can get on the
same page about handling money and then
we can make decisions together
about handling money but you sit over
there whether you can't settle there
with his dad and make decisions for this
house unilaterally without your
involvement that's just wrong it's just
it's not the way you do relationships
not proper ones anyway hope that helps
thank you for calling open phones at
triple-eight eight two five five two two
five you jump in we'll talk about your
life and your money we're glad you're
with us thanks for hanging out
so I will tell you that as we have
studied millionaires there are almost no
percentage-wise I mean it's it's less
than 10% of the millionaires that are
married that make decisions without
their spouse
there's your correlation
proverbs 31 says who can find a virtuous
wife for her worth is far above rubies
the heart of her husband safely trusts
her and he will have no lack of gain
I run a multi-million dollar
organization with a multi-million dollar
net worth an eye and the person that
people ask about money and I don't make
financial decisions of size without my
wife's involvement who has a home Ekta
Gris and raised three kids as her career
I don't do it without her input why
because she has wisdom and I want to
balance that out and balance out my gogo
with her no no this is the Dave Ramsey
show